I'll sagoo marasmus fear that like a
Mack desert why does he want me there's
like a gazillion people at this place
this is not funny
I don't play games except out lies Jesus
what is that bunnies very nice bunnies
god I love bunnies you look creepy oh
it's the computers all right we're in a
server room I bet he can't go here hello
I would soon as it go in one of the
lockers and just cry forever if I was in
this situation we have objectives to
complete and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that I'm going in and I
cry fighting you know this man
Oh chicken call me Tinker Bell's I think
you found me hi oh [ __ ] hurts yo I'm not
gonna come to you you better you have to
come I come I come I come I come up to
me
make a mess come back come back to me
Gracie oh god I hear something
where is he
if I know where he is it would be hell
you're pa'lante up I love that
I panic every time
I'm not a rat I'm a person I have
feelings and my feelings are not for you
sir listen up listen up we can do this
all day
now let's just sneak out oh we could
totally go out there can't couldn't we
huh please my [ __ ] life depends on it
thank you
oh my god they a really mean okay that
really really made okay gasps room I
feel like I should make an appropriate
joke when I'm not gonna okay there we go
there we go
objective nailed and close his door just
to be sure that he won't [ __ ] with me
again I would lock it if I were myself
but I'm not apparently all right let's
go in here how great we have to go back
I was hoping tonight it's Jeff yeah
great
yes who's back Jack again bullet a pie
he's so late
oh hello gasps me families now we just
got to sneak back up
I'm sure it's 100% not safe all right I
hit him fart off in the distance this is
fine this is that dish very good sorry
the gas all right there it is
spotted as spotted which we could target
him and then we could like see him or
some [ __ ] but and Dutch is not good
right right going here I'm backing up
backing up maggara bagging it cuz my
dear dear touch make out America der
heul a to me and I'm I come oh my god oh
my god oh my god
[ __ ] me back for you Meredith in there I
think
I think that's what I think
let me go let me go I don't have any
toes let me go
no more chase no more chase I can't
handle it please for the love of God
stop it so me oh thank god oh thank god
sayonara arigato [ __ ] on my Plateau
all right nice little jog down here girl
a nice little jog down here hello what's
up hello hello what's up oh we're
outside oh that's wonderful I can just
climb on climb on oh I can is opening
shared okay let's find some [ __ ]
batteries because we really need that
[ __ ] batteries all right to die person
weird [ __ ] although he better not be out
there I swear he must be [ __ ] tagging
my ass or some [ __ ] cos strong this is
not normal this is not English give it
go in here why would I go in there now
well I want to stay outside right hello
hello hey man don't scream I'm just
gonna take a picture all right great
times
all right nothing spooky isn't going on
here I'm sure I am very sure about that
great fog best fog why do I have my
camera couple of that what was that what
was that what was that what was that
what was that what was that what was
that what was that what was that what
was that why do I keep asking it's not
like anyone's gonna answer and even you
do answer it's not gonna be anything
good all right that was fun whoa fun fun
fun fun lookin forward to the we in a
minute I'm way looking so fast now oh
hello great cool oh all right huh islet
paddle hail a paddle yay don't touch me
don't what
who's out there oh good bit Zeke raged
grandis my friend Sui
they were running that way why am i oh
god what is that sound
alright we got something here
alright the blood goes here so for some
reason I'm going here can't really
explain it no I don't like the string
orchestra music don't don't don't don't
go don't go there orchestra let me just
wash my feet alright perhaps we get yes
we can
maybe there's batteries here I have a
sense of direction of bad note as [ __ ]
the game really hates you this once you
to suffer
you know how in games oh [ __ ]
that looks nice in there
you know how in games when you can't
progress because there's like a stupid
day uh what is she you see playing
basketball loser
Wow I could hit that easy um there's
like a you know in games when the sack
of wool and you're like [ __ ] sake I
could just jump over it and you never
can oh god oh god no no no you get you
gotta let me in man this game just takes
that and you can actually do it but you
don't expect that you can do it so you
decide what the [ __ ] come on
Oh God what are these trampolines and
larger planes
alright well it looks like we're going
to press and block no okay I guess we're
not what about this where can't go
anyway oh now this is open what the
Frank awesome
finger paint with my toes love it
hey man you want it oh great chair
favorite chair whoa what is this
hello Oh more dead people so to kill
afford the guards that's not very nice
well what are you gonna do did it did it
to do
do did it whoop whoa what are you doing
you every time [ __ ] is your problem
whoop that was fun love this place
this is probably one of my favorite
places ever uh this game is so confusing
I feel so lost oh here we go
awesome progress yeah we're gonna play
black basketball I want a basketball I'm
in the prisoner block now why would I
enter a [ __ ] prison
don't Italy doesn't make sense
especially if a prison like this one
going leagues oh not those two again
don't do it penis man what are you
talking to
Oh God let me just close this cuz you're
[ __ ] insane oh god they're good
don't kill me why does it want to kill
make batteries when the man is counting
King cologne made wreaths when the
feeling's gone and you trampled upon oh
this is nothing
hi I'm the new kid on the block see you
guys better not make fun of me okay
whoa what happens when you lift too hard
bro
that's what you get bro that's what you
get bro thanks sorry okay and why don't
we do eat
I don't know oh hello that's what we do
this is how a partying mood bit wet your
bar dare cut my a trip back there yeah
dude it up man no we're not gonna go
there
Steff mode activate
I'm a shadow shadow you don't have a
swan penis me me me me
creepy you never saw this we never had
this conversation
I'm gone neck Dewayne works every time
I prefer to say Crouch Phil's that's
good
was that basketball guy again whoa watch
it sir I could have gotten hurt oh [ __ ]
they're after me aren't they
whoa slam does buddy's pork hey high
five
oh not that type of high five skin okay
I get it
okay you want to play you want to play
play brah you want to play brah all
right you know what
got it oh [ __ ] sigh oh yeah I am really
[ __ ] [ __ ] dressage skins or [ __ ]
off please why are you so just kiss your
ugly you want to touch them alright
touch him ah don't touch me all right
great times you know what I had a lot of
fun here learned a lot of lessons and
it's a Finland overall good experience I
would rated - million out of ten I bet
they can't climb ladders those stupid
[ __ ] oh great great fantastic oh okay
well we can if there's a whale Larry sub
[ __ ] all right Oh documents on the
feeling's gone in a Kane document if you
want to read that go ahead and pause
right now go if you're a boy you're not
allowed to do it as some sexist as some
people and you're getting two thumbs up
you had enough on - I thought you wanted
rap you're an abandoned I want your
father why dagger sorry
what are you doing what okay cool sorry
I keep missing everything because I'm so
[ __ ] everywhere if you have to be
otherwise you miss everything that was
not that well I guess up it's the only
way my name showed it don't trust them
they'll tell you it's science but it's
not they were waiting for us in this
place
hey Billie understood Billy they've
always been it's all been here Billy
it's okay it's okay Billy it's gonna be
okay Billy I'm gonna make millions
now take your paints off girl Billy I'm
gonna have to need you to cooperate with
me either my suit doesn't work take your
damn pants off before I get angry
I'm coming back for you [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] Billy restored this door best
or favorite door in the world should
have known no thank you
I'm really sorry but we're gonna have to
in this episode hey leave a like if you
enjoy watching and I'll see your
beautiful face tomorrow behind